like it should be a joke factor it's not
well maybe someone better we came out
like two months before the the Lincoln
movie with Daniel day-lewis rushed it
out that guy's amazing by the way yeah
but that was another movie that bothered
me I saw the Daniel day-lewis Lincoln
movie was kind of dull too slow yeah but
it bothered me that we don't really know
what the [ __ ] this guy said it's one
thing like there will be blood which was
[ __ ] amazing yeah but those are fake
people man he looked good as Lincoln
crazy crazy how good they made him out
remember gangs in New York when he was
Bob the butcher but was it bill bill the
butcher yeah
he's phenomenal he's great in everything
yeah hi so good man he's just one of
those guys it just becomes completely
there's one there's a few people that
there's a lot of people that are actors
that are just weirdos they're just these
really strange people that desperately
want attention they figured out a way to
use their mental illness to navigate the
waters of Hollywood and some strange way
where their virtue signalling and and
and behaving exactly the way Hollywood
wants them to behave to get themselves
into these positions of fame and then
they become movie stars and then say a
bunch of nonsense and these you hear
them interviewed you like you're not
even a person like it's not a person
it's not a person talking there's no
sincerity there's no reality to we you
just painfully aware of every word
you're saying and how people are gonna
perceive it and you just know there's no
soap your your guards never down there
just weirdos yeah and then there's
people like Daniel day-lewis who's just
this savage it just figures out how to
become these people these days that's a
real deal yeah yeah I mean he [ __ ]
stays in character that was great last
the Mohicans he's so good he's [ __ ]
great and everything you retired you
know he does now huh makes shoes are you
serious yeah there's a cobbler he makes
shoes by hand that's what he does Wow
he's a legend
dude he kami man he's so good Hilda
butcher yeah yeah I would fly to
wherever the [ __ ] he is to get a shoe
made by him I should do it I should what
if we make shoes for people probably
just make shoes for his friends what
it's like does he have a company like I
know he makes shoes but what like what
do with these goddamn shoes what's his
lifestyle like not I mean after all that
like you know I was saying like all
those crazy moments like a human
potential like you know his human
potential of his like acting craft like
during my class Mohicans and and gangs
and New York and stuff yeah like going
from that like extreme those extreme
highs and yeah you know performance
levels to making shoes that's it's crazy
usually people go up not not you know up
in intensity not down in intensity right
right yeah the intensity aspect of it is
really interesting but I think for him
like he's he's such an artist that I
don't think he cares whether or not
people are looking at his art I think he
cares about the process of creating yeah
so I think tie the same to him yeah I
think that's us well maybe even it's
more pure because of the fact that it
doesn't have any adulation there's no
there's no spotlight on it
there's no publicity team there's no
stupid interviews he has to do yeah you
know yeah that stuff must be maddening
you know for him to sit down with
someone from [ __ ] Entertainment
Television so mad you got another dope
movie coming out
tell us about it sounds like you need a
Daniel day-lewis on the on the podcast
here maybe even amazing but maybe he
would how cool would that be to talk
about shoes he probably be psyching on
that maybe yeah I would talk to that guy
for three hours just about shoes he's
awesome if he was into just tell me
about your stitching process where do
you choose your leather I don't think
from what I just read I don't think that
he does it it says that he took time off
from making movies to study under this
very well-known shoemaker for 10 months
specifically and only did now then he
came back though he made a movie like
last year called the phantom thread
which where he was a desire fashion
designer and then he learned to in order
to do that he'd reverse engineered a
Balenciaga dress and just to learn how
to become a fashion what is a Balenciaga
dressed you know that we pulled up it's
blends tigers of a company it's like
they make that shirt we made with little
shirt things so it's at the high-end
very high-end stuff it's hard yeah and
then put it back together so we could
understand the process of doing it mmm
that was like his that's how he became
it got into character for the for that
movie so I don't know if he's retired
all the way doesn't seem like he makes
who
levy retired I mean he made that movie
last year though this is my 17 yeah that
for a while he like six there's only one
way to find out you did return yeah he
took some time off is it Daniel if
you're out there anytime dude just just
holler at me I know you don't have a
better dog I know you don't have a
Twitter but I got people you got people
he was amazing in the movie the boxer
too in my opinion no good he played the
most believable professional boxer in a
film because a lot of films like even
like the movie with Marky Mark where he
played Micky Ward it was like Mark
Wahlberg knows how to punch he knows how
to throw punches but there's a
difference between throwing punches in a
movie and a guy throwing punches in a
fight and if you look at the way Daniel
day-lewis is performing in that boxing
movie he looks like a guy who's throwing
punches in a fight it's way more
realistic than any boxing movie I've
ever seen and he boxed for a full year
before he did that movie
you mean just lived in a boxing gym he
trained all the time sparred hit the
pads he got real coaching from he played
a guy who was an IRA guy who got out of
jail and then got back into boxing and
then there's a bunch of terrorist [ __ ]
involved in the film's very good movie
but see if you can find footage of him
from that movie so when when you see
boxing movies guys are throwing punches
like they're not gonna get hit back yeah
like this is a certain thing about
boxing like if you watch a guy actually
fighting there's a tension oh yeah
there's a tension to worry about hole
getting hit back and you see a movie
about a boxer goes I hear you man it's
just too much the mitts are down they're
just like yeah Chin's out it's not just
that it's like the way they're moving
there's no anticipation there's no it's
all offense right yeah all even when
they're getting hit it's [ __ ] it's
like there's and you can tell it makes
it drives me crazy
yeah trees like watch him in here I mean
this guy he studied and trained I forget
who was training him but it was like
legit professional boxers see crazy that
commitment that these guys need to take
their acting to the next level because
it's like there's not that many people
who even note
say he fights more like a real fighter
yeah I'm saying no there's not but even
like silica the waste throwing these
punches like this is the way a real
boxer throws punches like they're not
wide yeah everything's real tight pretty
[ __ ] impressive but I mean I would
expect nothing else from this guy